[Musique]
les biens d'un côté du bord de l'eau
c'est quand on fait de la finition d'un
gros un bus et why you donc c'est un
croisement à la ferme on environ une
dizaine de taureaux
radio qu'on a couple avec des vaches et
engels
nous sommes dakar balle en abitibi-ouest
antoine bord de l'eau et éleveur de
boeuf depuis quatre générations avec sa
conjointe le riz côté sarrazin il
développe un produit de niche le boeuf
angus with you
le what your own alata de plus en plus
par lille donc c'est vraiment elle
viendrait le chercher là pour sa
tendreté a raison de faire sciages
justement lui qui m'a font tour à la
puissante y avait un petit goût de
noisette de beurre aussi qui recherchait
cette race bovine venus du japon est
très prisé dans les grands restaurants
et séduit de plus en plus de
consommateurs
wyoming russe on arrive à vendre des
ebooks en tant que futur bus question
n'avait par exemple ça pour ça voyou
mais un concert voix dans la tendreté le
voyou puis il a compté une gueuse ceci
nous permet de démocratiser le radio
parce qu'on center l'aide avant l'été
des stages un petit peu moins cher
chaque semaine durant la belle saison la
remorque des côtés bord de l'eau fait
son apparition dans les marchés publics
de l'abitibi
au menu des coupes varié de viande
congelée sous vide le reste de l'année
il livre partout dans la région
mais j'allais à l'unité ou si seul
problème l'abitibi-témiscamingue n'a
plus d'abattoir provincial depuis vingt
ans les bêtes doivent donc faire un
voyage de plus de 800 kilomètres pour
être abattus près de sherbrooke
les douves a trop souffert nous on doit
suivre les règles compter mapaq donc on
doit les faire abattre nos bêtes en
estrie où est-ce que de la cave des
abattoirs provincial donc nous on
retrouve pas seul 6-1 abitibi
[Musique]
pourtant à 100 km au sud en banlieue de
rouyn noranda les éleveurs de boeuf
christelle groulx et sylvain pleurant
son propriétaire de la boucherie desprat
un abattoir dits de proximité
mais cet abattoir a ses limites
proximité en fait c'est un abattoir où
l'inspecteur est pas là en tout temps on
a les mêmes règles à respecter mais on
n'est pas inspecté continuellement comme
les autres types d'abattoirs qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'au québec il ya trois
types d'abattoirs et la proximité sous
inspection permanente provincial puis
sous inspection permanente fédéral
ce petit abattoir est bien pratique pour
ces éleveurs installés à rimini dans le
nord du témiscamingue ce qu'elle forme
c'est qu'on fait l'élevage ont fait
l'abattage ont fait la déco si on fait
la description du trièves dalphond ont
fait la chasse au complet c'est sûr
cannabis musicalement on est les seuls à
hadath notre province a découpé notre
propre et belle preuve en honneur à ba3
de proximité qui nous permette soirée
avec leur abattoir de proximité
ils peuvent donc vendre leur viande mais
à certaines conditions
la commercialisation de cette viande là
est plus restreinte moi ce que j'abats
ici c'est vraiment pour une vente
directe au consommateur la viande peut
pas se retrouver dans une épicerie dans
un restaurant pourquoi si la
réglementation qui est comme ça parce
que c'est pas de la viande qui est
respectée de façon permanente pour
laurie antoine cet abattoir de proximité
n'est donc pas une solution et je
pourrais pas
je prépare la revendre sur le marché la
can on peut afin que la bataille mais
seulement pour ma consommation
personnelle
à 200km de carval nous voici à knowlton
dans le nord de l'ontario à vingt
minutes du témiscamingue
charles bélanger s'occupe de la ferme
familiale bisons du nord fondé par son
père et son grand père il ya cinquante
ans on est rendu à un trou qui consiste
de 3,5 bison mais avec vos futurs
jusqu'à 400 un bail de quatre saisons
avec les vous vous avez un abattoir ici
pas loin on a va trop loin oui à belval
et qui est encore plus proche du québec
fecq 15 minutes l'abattoir ici sénat ba
3 provincial et je peux le vendre
tous partout en ontario avec cet
abattoir pour les bélanger l'abitibi
témiscamingue est un marché intéressant
mais inaccessible ça serait quoi le
potentiel s'il y avait un abattoir
provence hier au bella potentiels sont
parle de juger accès à 150000 personnes
de plus le témiscamingue ontarien et
québécois on est tous pareils on est
tous de la même place mais une frontière
en ou deux puis ça on parle de doubler
notre marché au québec en l'absence d'un
abattoir provincial en abitibi bisons du
nord n'a pas accès à ce marché de
consommateurs québécois car il vient
faire abattre ici c'est uniquement pour
la commercialisation via de la bûche
libre il pourrait s'y amènerait ces
bisons vivent dans un abattoir
provincial du côté du québec en fait
l'abattoir provincial que ça permettrait
c'est que les viandes qui seraient
abattus dans cet abattoir le prêt de
commercialiser partout dans les petites
boucheries dans les restaurants
dans les kiosques à la ferme s'il n'y
aurait pas de limite dans le fond si ce
n'est que c'est de préparer à
l'exportation parce que ce sont les
règles entre le fédéral et le provincial
mais sinon les gens qui voudraient même
rentrer dans certains épiciers pour elle
si on résume les bêtes travers ses
frontières mais pas les morceaux de
viande exactement à moins que il ya eu
un drapeau qui canado dessus
[Musique]
aussi l'habitude de manger local les
poussées l'achat local ça serait donc
pratique d'avoir un abattoir provincial
exact c'est la prochaine étape
on est dans le processus mais c'est sûr
qu est-ce qui ne se présente pas sous
les coups les coûts sont très élevés au
rang d'objet de on est éreinté budget
autour des 10 millions bon appétit ce
qu'on va en avoir assez
le financement de cet abattoir
provincial est loin d'être ficelé mais
christelle et sylvain garde espoir on a
pris un peu de recul pour ne regarder ce
qu'on s'est dit mais on est on est déjà
en opération dès déjà une infrastructure
certains peau neuve aussi mais on sait
qu'on regarde pour modifier moderniser
celle qu'on ne
en attendant laurie antoine voit
l'avenir d'un autre oeil avec les
volumes qui augmente le de noé et voyous
en bus bouvillons fini et l'on y prenne
jetterait dans les prochaines années
enfin le souhait sans pubs et
restaurants des hôtels ont vraiment plus
se concentrer à exporter notre viande de
l'habitude d'y voir montréal c'est pour
sauver des nouveaux marchés une étape à
la fois mais on aimerait beaucoup elle
commercialise à plus grande échelle
[Musique]